I Jack aggression a prince ali
understanding and understandings are
sort of a stalking horse in a way but i
think the votes he got really some of
them would be anti Blatter rather than
throw Ali and I I think they were
probably stronger candidates out there
not necessarily for the personal point
of view but candidates who represents
bigger Confederations there may be
someone from from from within Africa or
Asia but it will need someone on real
stature of undoubted integrity and
someone who could really handle a very
big unwieldy organization I've got no
names for sure this stage but um I think
we'll do the sort of characters a day if
they emerge but I feeling is it may it
may not be Prince Ali maybe somebody
else will come along possibly for my a
bigger area and of course they're going
to have a huge job on their hands are
they just tell us the the challenges
ahead 54 now to rebuild and rebrand
itself well I've got to really get the
government source cloud they've got to
get the ball sorted out they've got to
get credibility back into the
organization they've got the world cup
bits to sort out and that cause that
enormous particularly i believe the
qatar bit which has all sorts of issues
surrounding it so this is a big job but
there's quite how it's quite doable not
in a way the Beast will be such a relief
but latter having gone is in so many
quarters that this person will have a
lot of goodwill I think to start with so
you know it's get so crowded in a way
quite an end available position it's
like having after Alex focus on you know
the great manager and you see if you
can't you can replace him you know this
is a match in and went away a much
easier situation coming into someone
who's ended up being such a disaster
okay David Bernstein thank you